my move University YouTube videos are
offered on a pay what you like basis if
you'd like to pay for the use of the
videos visit my website at move
University comm click on the pay what
you like link at the top of the page and
follow the instructions on that page
thank you and enjoy since we talked
about carnitine in the previous video
I'd like to provide you with little
clinical correlate in this video so we
mentioned the carnitine mediated
transport system of basal Koei's in the
previous video and why that was
important for specifically the pathway
of beta oxidation now there obviously
can be deficiencies in the role players
of that pathway so as I mentioned before
we had carnitine we had cat1 cat2 and
then the carnitine acyl carnitine
translocase protein as well
now deficiencies in any of these can be
a problem specifically what what will
happen or not happen is is the question
of what which pathways will be impaired
well we know that these are all involved
in the carnitine mediated transport of
the carnitine mediated transport of acyl
Koei's from the cytosol to the
mitochondrial matrix so if there are
deficiencies in those role players that
are involved in that process what will
happen well the transport of a soak away
from the cytosol to the mitochondrial
matrix will be impaired in fact it won't
happen right so if we're not getting a
silk aways from the cytosol to the
mitochondrial matrix then beta-oxidation
cannot happen
right which is a problem why is it a
problem well let's talk specifically
about a carnitine deficiency now I'm not
really certain about these other guys I
know that because they're all enzymes or
proteins that that are involved in this
pathway or should be this transport
system they deficiencies in these guys
right here because there are proteins
they are coded for by DNA so
deficiencies can be due to genetics
right so those are genetic diseases when
you have deficiencies or those and I
think they're pretty rare I'm not sure
what the details of all of them but in
fact even even the carnitine deficiency
can be genetic I'm not too sure about
the causes of all these things but I do
want to mention a little bit about the
consequence of a carnitine deficiency if
someone doesn't have carnitine then then
you can't form acyl carnitine and if you
can't form a so carnitine then you can't
get a so Koei's to the mitochondrial
matrix for where beta oxidation can
happen so what's the consequence of that
Quarantine deficiency is that you can't
utilize fatty acids for energy right you
can't use these activated fatty acids
for energy and that's a really bad thing
because fatty acids are a sort of long
term energy source whereas like
something like free glucose and our cell
can be readily used immediately glycogen
is a short term energy source as well
but when we're fasting or if we're
exercising for long periods of time for
instance if you take you know if you jog
for a few miles
that's an extended period of time and if
you're fasting which means if you're not
eating all your body is being fueled by
fatty acids so you cannot utilize fatty
acids for energy during fasting or
extended periods of exercise if you have
a carnitine deficiency and that can
cause a multitude of things including
muscle cramps right or muscle weakness
can be pretty pretty severe and this
could even cause death if it if it
affects the story is if actually affects
specifically the muscle kidney and heart
cells mostly and I mean those things are
pretty important right if those things
are weak or not working then that could
result in death so which is a symptom
that's not really treatable as you
probably already know so the question is
how can carnitine deficiency be treated
well I read about it a little bit and
it's apparently little bit complicated
but the simple answer the simplest
answer I can give is carnitine
supplements and that sounds pretty
simple right if someone doesn't have
carnitine you just give them that
carnitine right just an amino acid if
you just give someone carnitine then
that should be work that should work
right and apparently that is the case in
but it's it sounds simpler than it
actually is and I'm not really sure
about all the details but the idea
simply is that if someone doesn't have
carnitine you give them carnitine then
they can start using these fatty acids
for energy during their fasting period
or during exercise and they won't have
to worry about these symptoms and
apparently that is the case people who
have carnitine deficiencies are treated
with carnitine supplements and but that
needs to be like highly like monitored
and regulated and like they need to be
really careful about the way it happens
I'm not really sure about the details
I'm not a doctor tonight I'm by no means
offering medical advice I'm just trying
to approach this from an academic
perspective um another thing though is
that some people use carnitine
supplements just as a dietary supplement
not add not as a sort of treatment for a
deficiency so the idea is that if
someone has more carnitine what could
happen well that could enhance transport
of a so Koei's into the mitochondrial
matrix at least this is the reasoning
you can enhance the transport of my a so
Koei's into the mitochondrial matrix
which means that beta oxidation could
happen more often and it's marketed as a
supplement that could help you increase
your endurance and even help you lose
weight so what's the reasoning behind
that with the reason those things
are are offered or market in that way
well the idea is that if you have more
acyl Koei's coming into the
mitochondrial matrix faster
beta-oxidation can happen more often and
for maybe for prolonged periods so um if
you're jogging right and you have more
you're able to tap on fatty acids more
and more more then perhaps your
endurance can can be increased because
of that so that's that's the reasoning
behind that or at least you know that
the the short bit of reasoning behind
that and the reasoning behind promoting
weight loss is that well I mean fatty
acids where do they come from well they
come from triacylglycerols which are
fats and if you are constantly
activating fatty acids turning them into
a SoCo ways and getting those a souca
ways into the mitochondria to be broken
down via beta oxidation then you're
burning fat and the more if this happens
more via a carnitine supplement then you
could lose weight that's the idea behind
that and from what I've read um which
was not too much to be honest um I don't
know if there's like a sort of clear
clear-cut like definitely this work sort
of thing there might be some evidence
that suggests that it works but it's
it's not clear that it's like a proven
thing which is probably why I don't
really hear too much about it in terms
of like a weight loss supplement but
that's just a little tidbit of knowledge
I figured I'd share thanks for watching